now we're not the only country with an
illegal immigration problem of course
we've seen this Royal Europe Sweden for
example used to be one of the most
welcoming Nations for refugees who
wanted to resettle there but following a
series of riots and a stark rise in
crime that's linked to the migrants they
said no more and they reduced the number
allowed to come into the country the
country's new prime minister started
what is a dramatic shift to Sweden first
last year and Poland well they have a
different approach they have a very
strict immigration uh system there
they've accepted some refugees from
neighboring Ukraine but they will not
allow in people from elsewhere even if
they're seeking Asylum my next guest a
Polish member of the European Parliament
is going viral for what he said this
week about illegal immigration and the
Biden Administration they should take
note the lowest unemployment in European
Union is
Poland the highest GDP after coid in
European Union is Poland one of the
lowest debts in European Union is
Poland so don't give us this rubbish
about the need of
educated immigration we don't need your
doctors we don't need your engineers
take them take them all and pay for them
we don't need them you know you know why
because there is a zero terrorist
attacks in Poland why because because
there is no illegal migration in Poland
so don't give me this look don't give me
this arguments about the populism
because this is a fact this is your
data joining me now is Dominique trinsky
who is a Polish member of the European
Parliament you just saw in that video
Dominique it's great to see you tonight
now than you very the EU decided the the
EU decided that this Refugee um
welcoming was very important and a
positive development for Europe all of
Europe and they look down on people like
you and Poland in general for its
decision to say no we have to support
and protect our culture which does not
include you know the wahhabist Islamic
uh Outlook and wahhabist policies and
traditions and you
say we don't care well there's a
difference between Refugee and migrant
especially illegal migrant as a lawyer
I'm trying to repeat it every single
time for years now they are not refugees
they are criminals those who are trying
to cross the border illegally are
criminals and as a criminal should be
deported and there is no discussion
about it our policy is very straight
zero not even one never ever will come
to Poland if it's illegal if he's trying
to cross our border illegally he will be
punished and deported not welcomed as as
we heard we're not going to pay for them
we're not going to fit them in the
beautiful rooms in hotels or anywhere
else they will not stay on polish soil
they will not stay in Poland Poland as I
said in Parliament and I'm trying to
repeat it Poland is the only country in
the European Union without any terror
attack we haven't had any Terror attacks
in Poland because there is no illegal
migration that's why every single time
I'm trying to say be like Poland be
brave believe in your own Nations but
most of these spineless politicians in
here in Brussels are destroying their
own countries I must say uh Mr Trump was
right about the wall he built a
beautiful wall can you imagine America
now without a wall Poland build it a
wall we have a great hall and no one is
able to enter no one is able to come to
Poland and as we promised our government
promised in
2015 not even one will come to Poland
ever well Dominique Dominique you will
continue to support allowing Ukrainian
um refugees genuine refugees into Poland
during this war
correct well you have to remember that
our situation is completely different
than than America than Americans um we
are neighboring country with Ukraine and
by the international law those who came
to Poland over two million mainly women
and and children are honest uh genuine
refugees but our law was changed for
some time to support them support them
financially support them with education
with the health care and all they need
to to live in Poland but for uh for many
reasons recently Mr zalinski seems very
ungrateful I must say and our law might
be changed we don't have to uh support
them with all these benefits like
financial support we don't have to do it
we want it we wanted to do it we we
decided to do it well but we don't have
to do it anymore and I think our
contracts while ended will not be
extend all right Dominique it's great to
see you I'm half polish so of course I
love interviewing the polls thank you so
much for joining hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else